♪ ♪
>> STILL LOTS OF AMAZING MOMENTS
COMING UP IN THE SHOW, WE'VE GOT
PERFORMANCES AND OF COURSE THE
GAME OF THE YEAR ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
OKAY.
>> THIS IS JOKER, I'VE
INFILTRATED THE THEATER.
>> HE WENT ALONE TO THE GAM
AWARDS?
IT'S SO FAR AWAY, WHY HE IS HE
THERE.
>> HE'S THERE TO STEAL A
TREASURE.
>> WE AREN'N'T THE ONE SENDING A
CARD THIS TIME.
WE'VE BEEN INVITED.
INVITED TO STEAL THE GREATEST
TREASURE OF ALL.
SMASH BROTHERS, IS THIS FOR
REAL?
WILL BE GOING UP AGAINST THE
BEST OF THE BEST.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE OUR FEARLESS
LEADER SHOW IT.
>> I AM -- RAGE AGAINST ALL
CHALLENGERS.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: OH REGGIE, WE MEET
AGAIN.
QUITE THE SURPRISE.
SUPER SMASH BROTHERS COMING OUT
TONIGHT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE A
GREAT CHOICE OF SHIRT.
THE INTERNET IS GOING CRAZY THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF JOKER FROM
PERSONA FIVE COMING TO SMASH
BROTHERS.
>> WE'VE SAIAID SUPER SMASH
BROTHERS ULTIMATE THE BIGGEST
CROSSOVER IN VIDEO GAME HISTORY,
DARE I SAY THE BIGGEST CROSSOVER
AND ENTERTAINMENT.
>> THE RUSSO BROTHERS MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
>> THE GAME IS ABOUT TO LAUNCH,
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED, SUPER
EXCITED TO GIVE THE FANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUMMON A PERSONA
INTO THE GAME.
>> Geoff: YOU SAID CHALLENGER
PACK ONE >> EACH CHARACTER WILL
COME WITH THE STAGE, A SELECTION
OF MUSIC, THESE WILL BE CHARACTT
ARE NEW TO THE SERIES JUST LIKE
JOKER FROM PERSONA FIVE,
CHARACTERS THAT YOU WOULD NOT
ANTICIPATE TO BE IN SUPER SMASH
BROTHE ULTIMATE.
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
THE FANS CAN GO AND GET THE
FIGHTERS PASS TO GET ALL OF THE
FIVE FIGHTERS, WE ARE
TREMENDOUSLY EXCITED.
>> Geoff: TONIGHT, SMASH IS
ABOUT TO LAUNCH.
>> SMASH IS ABOUT TO LAUNCH.
YOU KNOW YOU NEEDED TO HAVE A
REALLYOOD SHOW R ME TO BE
HERE, MAKING SURE EVERYTHING I
GOING GREAT FOR THE LAUNCH.
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED,, SMASH IS
MINUTES AWAY AND WE
IT'S GOINO
BE FANANTASTIC.
>> Geoff: : YOU'VE BEEN N RE
EVERY YEAR.
BEFORE WE GO, MAYBE WE SHOULD
HEAD FOR THE STAGE TO
FOR "THE
AWARDS" ORCHESTRA, MAY BE A
LITTLE SOMETHING FOR SUPER SMASH
BROTHERS.
♪ ♪